Have you seen this
footage of all of these rockets
raining down on to Israel?
They're calling this Israel's 9/11
because it totally caught them off guard.
And it's one of the most ambitious attacks
in a really long time.
The rockets were fired
by a group called Hamas,
which refuses Israel's
right to even exist.
For decades,
Hamas has protested Israel's
occupation of Palestinian territory
by launching missiles
from this small slice
of Palestine down here
called the Gaza Strip.
But this attack
was more deadly than normal.
It's killed at least
700 Israelis, most of them
civilians and thousands more wounded.
Israel immediately
declared war against Hamas
and the Israeli
air force began dropping bombs, killing
hundreds of Palestinian civilians.
They’re activating
300,000 of their reservists
to get ready to fight.
They're promising
that this is just the beginning.
I'll be following this conflict
as it unfolds and helping
you understand it in case
you want to follow for more.